♪ ♪
>> Greg: AMERICANS ARE FILLED
WITH DREAD AS STORE SHELVES ARE
AS EMPTY AS THE PRESIDENTS 'HAS
HAD.
AND THE SOLUTION FOR THIS MESS
IS YOU EXPECTING LESS.
THE ECONOMY IS HEADING FOR BRUIN
BUT BE HAPPY WE ARE BECOMING THE
SOVIET UNION.
HERE'S THE MAKING CONCERNED ANY
AVERAGE AMERICAN MIGHT HAVE.
SUPPLY CHAIN CRUSHING BUSINESSES
AND CONSUMERS AND SECRET
LATE-NIGHT FLIGHTS TO NEW YORK
CARRYING UNDERAGE MIGRANTS PAID
LAST TIME THEY BOOKED FLIGHTS
LIKE THAT IT WAS
JEFFREY EPSTEIN.
HOW DARE YOU.
AND A TRILLION DOLLARS SPENDING
BILL THAT WILL DRAG DOWN THE
ENTIRE -- SEEMS LIKE A GOOD TIME
FOR THE WHITE HOUSE TO PROVIDE
SOME CLARITY, RIGHT, JEN?
>> CRYSTAL CLEAR THAT THINGS
WERE NOT IMPROVING.
THIS WASHERS FURNITURE AND
TREADMILLS DELIVERED ON TIME.
NOT TO MENTION ALL SORTS OF
OTHER THINGS.
>> SPEAK OF THE TRAGEDY OF THE
TREADMILL THAT IS DELAYED.
>> WHY IS THE ADMINISTRATION
FLYING THOUSANDS OF MIGRANTS
FROM FLORIDA AND DASHED TO THE
MIDDLE OF THE NIGHT.
>> NOT SURE IT'S IN THE MIDDLE
OF THE NIGHT.
>> VERY EARLY IN THE MORNING.
>> EARLY FLIGHTS.
EARLIER THAN YOU MIGHT LIKE TO
TAKE A FLIGHT.
>> BUILD BACK BETTER WILL NOT AT
A DIME TO THE NATIONAL DEBT
QUESTION MIKE >> IT'S WON'T.
>> WHY SHOULD AMERICANS BELIEVE
THAT?
>> BECAUSE IT WON'T.
>> Greg: I HAVE TO HAND AT
HER.
SHE REALLY LOOKS ON THE BRIGHT
SIDE OF THINGS.
HER GLASS IS HALF-FULL WHICH IS
BETTER THAN OUR GROCERY SHELVES.
I WONDER IF SHE IS LIKE THAT ALL
THE TIME.
>> BACK I JUST STOLE MY BAG.
>> THAT'S GREAT.
NOW YOU WON'T HAVE TO CARRY IT
AND YOUR POSTURE WILL PROBABLY
IMPROVE.
>> THAT BACK HAD MY WALLET AND
IT.
>> NOW IT HAS BEEN REDISTRIBUTED
TO THE UNDERPRIVILEGED CRIMINAL.
KIND OF SELFISH TO YOU TO KEEP
THOSE.
>> Greg: I WISH I HAD THAT
POSITIVE OUTLOOK BUT IT'S NO
WONDER THAT TEAM BIDEN IS OKAY
WITH THAT.
WHEN YOU ARE IN COGNITIVE
DECLINE YOU DON'T REMEMBER THE
BETTER TIME.
A "WASHINGTON POST" WHICH MAKES
THE WHOLE THING REDUNDANT WHEN I
SAY IT IS "THE WASHINGTON POST"
TWICE OP-ED ARGUES THAT YOU
SHOULD NOT COMPLAIN ABOUT LACK
OF SERVICES OR LABOR SHORTAGES.
INSTEAD, JUST LOWER YOUR
EXPECTATIONS YOU DON'T.
YOU DON'T HAVE TO WAIT IN LINE
FOR BREAD IF YOU DON'T WANT TO.
YOU CAN JUST STARVE OR EMBRACE
THE WEIGHT.
AND RAISING MEANS THE GOVERNMENT
HAS TO DO WORK.
WE EVEN MADE YOU A HANDY VIDEO
TO HELP AMERICANS GET ON BOARD.
♪ ♪
>> HEY THERE, KIDDOS.
HAVE YOU HEARD ABOUT THE
SO-CALLED NATIONAL SUPPLY CHAIN
CRISIS?
THERE IS A LOT OF MISINFORMATION
GOING AROUND BUT THE TRUTH IS
WITH A SHORTAGE OF GOODS,
THERE'S NEVER BEEN A BETTER TIME
TO LOWER YOUR LIFE'S
EXPECTATIONS.
SURE THERE MIGHT BE BREAD LINES
BUT HEY, WHAT A GREAT WAY TO
MEET YOUR NEIGHBORS.
NO TOILET PAPER ON THE SHELVES?
NO PROBLEM.
YOU ARE ALSO EATING MUCH LESS.
RISING GAS PRICES?
THAT MEANS LESS MONEY FOR YOUR
CRIPPLING PILL ADDICTION.
AND LESS DRIVING IS A GREAT WAY
TO GET YOUR STEPS IN FOR THE
DAY, COMRADE.
THE SOONER YOU LOSE TO LOVE
SOVIET SENSATION THIS UNION WILL
COME TO THE REALIZATION THAT THE
AMERICAN DREAM WAS A NIGHTMARE.
AND REMEMBER, YOU HAVE HAD IT
TOO EASY TO LONG.
SPEAK OUT TOO EASY, TOO LONG.
CHARLIE.
KIND OF INTERESTING.
IT DOES NOT SEEM THAT PSAKI'S,
IS NOT EVEN TRYING ANYMORE.
IT'S AS THOUGH MEDIA HAS LOWERED
THEIR EXPECTATIONS FOR HER AND
SHE IS MEETING THEM.
>> AND A LOT OF WAYS, SHE IS
LIKE THE PERFECT PRESS SECRETARY
FOR THIS ADMINISTRATION.
COMPLETELY OUT OF HER DEPTH,
COMPLETELY HAS NO IDEA WHAT SHE
IS TALKING ABOUT ON A REGULAR
BASIS, BUT THE WORST, OF COURSE,
IS WHEN SHE COMES UP WITH THE
FUNDING QUIPS AND TRIES TO DO
COMEDY.
IT IS INSULTING.
IT IS RIDICULOUS.
AND OBVIOUSLY NOT FUNNY.
AND IN ONE OF THOSE CLUBS, CAN'T
REMEMBER IF YOU SHOWED IT RIGHT
THERE, WHICH SHE IS TALKING
ABOUT THE SUPPLY CHAIN AND SHE
SAYS WE ARE NOT THE POST OFFICE.
AND IT'S LIKE ACTUALLY YOU ARE.
AND IT'S TERRIBLE.
BUT IT'S -- IT'S ALSO A
REMINDER, TALKING ABOUT SILVER
LININGS, THERE WAS A GREAT
SILVER LINING IN BEING IN A 40
YEAR NUCLEAR STANDOFF WITH THE
SOVIET UNION.
WE WERE REMINDED OF WHAT
SOCIALISM REALLY WAS LIKE.
AND PEOPLE TALKED ABOUT IT.
AND PEOPLE ESCAPED WITH TELL YOU
STORIES ABOUT BREAD LINES AND I
GUESS WE'RE JUST GOING TO HAVE
TO WHATEVER, 30, 40 YEARS LATER,
JUST GOING TO HAVE TO DISCOVER
ON OUR OWN.
>> Greg: THINK OF IT AS AN
ADVENTURE.
THAT'S WHAT I DO WITH EVERYTHING
BAD.
>> JOE, IF YOU MARRY JEN PSAKI,
HER NAME WOULD BE JEN PSAKI
MACHI.
I'M GETTING A PAUSE FROM LARA
LOGAN OVER THAT TERRIBLE JOKE.
>> DON'T YOU HAVE A QUESTION,
GREG?
>> Greg: THAT IS MY QUESTION.
WHY HAVE YOU NOT MARRIED
JEN PSAKI?
>> I BELIEVE SHE IS TAKING AND I
AM AN HONORABLE MAN.
>> Greg: YOU LIVE A LIFE OF
LOWERED EXPECTATIONS.
SO WHAT IS YOUR FEELING?
>> THAT'S WHY THE TREADMILL QUIT
GLINTED FOR ME BECAUSE IF THERE
IS NO TREADMILL, THEN I HAVE THE
PERFECT EXCUSE FOR WHY I DON'T
HAVE TO USE THE TREADMILL.
I JUST THINK PEOPLE AREN'T
STUPID.
WHEN YOU'RE TRYING TO PUT
LIPSTICK ON A PIG EXCEPT RIGHT
NOW THERE IS NOT MUCH LIPSTICK
OR PIGGY.
PIG.
THE OTHER THING I FOUND
INSULTING WAS PEOPLE SAYING
JEN PSAKI SAYING THIS IS A SIGN
OF THE ECONOMY TAKING UP THE
GOODS ARE IN SHORT SUPPLY.
NO, I WAS NOT WAITING TO BUY
FOOD.
I AM ALWAYS LOOKING TO BUY FOOD.
>> Greg: THAT'S TRUE.
IT'S A VERY GOOD POINT.
I WISH I HAD COME UP WITH ADS.
KAT YOUR ENTIRE DATING LIFE WAS
FOCUSED ON LOW EXPECTATIONS.
BUT THEN IT CHANGED.
>> I HAVE BEEN MARRIED NOW FOR
ALMOST SIX MONTHS.
THANKS.
>> Greg: GOOD TO HAVE YOU
HERE.
>> SORRY ANYBODY WHO MIGHT HAVE
LOST MONEY.
READING THE ARTICLE.
IT'S ABSURD.
YOU CAN'T SAY THAT EVER.
IMAGINE IF A THERAPIST SAID
THAT.
DID IT EVER OCCUR TO YOU YOU
SHOULD JUST ACCEPT SWINGING
BETWEEN DEBILITATING ANXIETY AND
CRUSHING DEPRESSION QUESTION
MIKE HE WOULD ONLY HAVE TO GO TO
ONE SESSION BUT OTHER THAN THAT
THAT IS NOT EFFECTIVE.
NOBODY -- JEN PSAKI PUSH ON
THESE THINGS AND SHE GOES --
I COULD NOT DO THAT.
YOU COULDN'T DO THAT AND SAY
SOMETHING.
AND WHY?
WELL, 'CAUSE.
>> Greg: THAT'S TRUE.
LARA, LOW EXPECTATIONS ARE WHAT
YOU EXPECT WHEN YOU LEAVE
AMERICA.
YOU HAVE BEEN ALL OVER THE
WORLD.
SHE HAVE SEEN SOME PRETTY BAD
STUFF.
ARE WE OVERSTATING THIS?
>> NO.
WHAT IS HAPPENING HERE IS THAT
JEN PSAKI HAS JUST RUN OUT OF
ENERGY.
THERE ARE SO MANY CRISES ALL
OVER THE PLACE IT'S ALL COMING
APART.
THEY HAVE DONE THE WHOLE TACTIC
OF -- THEY ARE RUNNING OUT OF
LABOR.
IT'S EITHER QUEUING ON THE WHITE
SUPREMACIST OR THE ANTI-VAX
TERRORISTS.
SOMETHING LIKE THAT.
AND IT'S NOT WORKING ANYMORE.
PEOPLE ARE SMART AND THEY SEE
THROUGH IT AND THEY KNOW WHEN
THEY GO TO WALMART.
I LIVE IN A TOWN OF 11,000
PEOPLE, LUCKY TO HAVE ONE
WALMART.
THEY KNOW -- IT'S ONLY WELL ALL
MADE IN CHINA.
THEY ARE NOT STUPID AND THEY ARE
NOT FALLING FOR THE WHOLE
TREADMILL THING.
AND YOU KNOW WHAT IT IS?
IT IS CONSISTENT.
A MUCH MORE SIGNIFICANT
STRATEGY.
IF YOU NEVER ACKNOWLEDGE THAT
IT'S A CRISIS YOU NEVER HAVE TO
DO ANYTHING ABOUT IT.
THE BORDER IS NOT A CRISIS.
SO I DON'T HAVE TO DO ANYTHING
ABOUT IT.
THE AFGHANISTAN, THAT WAS NOT A
CRISIS, THAT WAS A HISTORIC
MOVEMENT OF PEOPLE SO WE DON'T
HAVE TO DO ANYTHING ABOUT THE
FACT THAT WE ARE ISOLATED ON THE
WORLD STAGE AT THE EXACT MOMENT
THAT CHINA'S LUNCH ON THE
SUPERSONIC MISSILE.
AND THIS KEEPS GOING.
BECAUSE THE SUPPLY CHAIN CRISIS
IS EXPOSING THE FACT THAT WE
DON'T MAKE ANYTHING AND WE DON'T
MAKE ENOUGH TO FEED AMERICA.
BUT DON'T WORRY, THEY'RE GOING
TO KILL ALL THE ANIMALS AND GIVE
YOU FOOD MADE IN A FACTORY.
THAT YOU DON'T KNOW WHAT IS AN
AD.
BUT BILL GATES HAS YOUR BACK.
>> Greg: I AM ALL FOR THE
FACTORY ANIMAL THING THOUGH
BE